so we have the strange-looking shape
here and then we're given some some of
its dimensions we know that this side
right over here has a has a length of
3.5 this side over here is 6.5 then we
know from here to here is 2 and then
from here to here is 7 and then they're
giving us this dimension right over here
is 3.5 and so given that let's see if we
can find the area of this entire of this
entire figure and i encourage you to
pause the video right now and try this
on your own
so i assume you've given a go at it and
there might be a few things that jump
out at you immediately the first thing
is that they have these two triangles up
here and they give us all of the
dimensions for them or at least they
give us the base and the height for it
which is enough to figure out the area
if i had a triangle if or if i had a
rectangle that was 2 times 3.4 or 2
wide 2 units wide and 3.5
units high if i had a rectangle like
that if i had a rectangle like that we
know that it would have an area of 2
times 3.5
now a triangle is just going to be or
especially a triangle like this a right
triangle is just going to be half of a
rectangle like this
we just care about half of its area
so this area is going to be one half
times two times three point five
and one half times two is equal to one
one times three point five is three
point five
square units so the area of that part is
going to be 3.5 square units
now let's think about the area of this
triangle right over here well once again
we have its height as 3.5 its base is 7.
so its area is going to be one half
times seven times three point five one
half times seven is three point five
times three
point five so this part is three point
five and i'm going to multiply that
times three point five again so let's
figure out what that product is equal to
so 3.5
times 3.5
5 times 5 is 25
3 times 5 is 15 plus 2 is
seventeen let's cross that out move one
place over to the left three times five
is fifteen
three times three
is nine plus one is ten
so that gets us to five plus five plus
zero is five
seven plus five is twelve carry the one
one plus one is two and we have a one
and we have two digits to the right of
the decimal one two so we're gonna have
two digits to the right of the decimal
in the answer so the area here is 12.25
square units
now this region might seem a little bit
more
maybe maybe a little bit more difficult
because it's kind of a this weird
trapezoid looking thing but one thing
that might pop out at you is that you
can divide it very easily into a
rectangle and a triangle and we can
actually figure out the dimensions that
we need to figure out the areas of each
of these we know what the width of this
rectangle is right or the length of this
rectangle whatever you want to call it
it's going to be 2 units plus 7 units so
this is going to be 9.
we know that this distance is 3.5
so this distance right over here is 3.5
then this distance down here adds has to
add up with 3.5 to 6.5 so this must be
this must be 3. so now we can actually
figure out the area
so the area of this rectangle is just
going to be its height times its length
or 9 times 3.5
9 times 3.5 and one way you could do it
we could even try to do this in our head
this is going to be 9 times 3 plus 9
times 0.5 so 9 times 3 is 27 9 times 0.5
that's just half of 9 so it's going to
be 4.5
plus 4 would get us to 31 so that's
going to be equal to
31.5 or you could multiply it out like
this if you like but the area of this
region is 31.5
and then the area of this triangle right
over here is going to be 9 times 3 times
1 half we're looking at a triangle
9 times 3 is 27 27 times one half is 13
13.5 and so to find the area of the
entire thing we just have to sum up
these areas so we have 31.5 31.5
plus 13.5
13.5
plus
12.25
plus 3.5
plus
3.5 here
so we just have a 5 here in the
hundredths that's the only one 5 plus 5
is 10 plus
is
17.
1 plus 1
is 2 plus 3 is five plus two is seven
plus three is ten
one plus three is four
plus one is five
plus one is six
so we get a total area for this figure
of
60.75
square units